welcome to my channel thank you for
watching my new series enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so this was a great frontier for you
personally to cross over into it a
paranormal theory about this yeah I was
raised in the strict materialist point
of view that the only things that were
real were things that you could touch
nock he'd look at and here people were
telling me experiences that could not be
photographed corroborated he'd get from
their point of view this was as real as
me standing in front of them and all the
people I talked with were describing the
exact same experiences without benefit
of any kind of details in the media they
could account for the cue there well do
you think that this is something that's
been going on for millennia or that this
is suddenly an event with a historical
element to it and that it is recent and
therefore building towards some sort of
resolution
there are folklorists who say that we
have been visited by little people for
centuries if not for millennia but this
form of visitation has a hard edge to it
that is different than what we've seen
before started with the Betty and Barney
Hill case and since then there have been
hundreds and moving out into the
thousands of reported cases which have a
kind of structure to it which is unlike
what we've had before there are
similarities to previous visitations but
the modern abduction phenomenon has a
distinction which has to be studied in
its own right and do you have an
interpretation of what that distinction
implies is it apocalyptic is it
technological what is it well I first
had to satisfy myself about what the
phenomenon was that it was not psychosis
it was not some strange dissociative
condition not some neurosis not some
contagion from the media in fact it has
no resemblance to any psychiatric
condition that in my 40 years of work in
this field I I had recognized it does
it's not some displaced abuse all those
things which naturally my colleagues and
I think of in relation this has its own
structure its own quality otherwise
saying people having these highly
traumatic very dense highly articulated
detailed congruous experiences which can
begin to be reported in children as
young as two years old associated with
UFOs in otherwise sane people so I had
to start by satisfying myself but this
was not something else okay then I can
begin from not from my own speculations
but from the information that the
abductees themselves get from the
experience I'm beginning to put together
a structure of what this is about and
what I'm getting is that if you could
think of the divine or if you can think
of the
the world of both spirit with form and
spirit without form or the anima Mundi
whatever your language for it the Great
Spirit the Holy Spirit whatever it is it
we have lost contact with it it signals
us we don't listen there are various
ways that certain people have
revelations and experiences occasionally
the more advanced spiritual people among
us are reconnecting with the spirit but
for most of us the only language that we
know now is the language of the material
world so it's as if the divinity say
okay if that's all you understand I'll
give it to you in the material world
I'll give you physical manipulations
I'll give you reproductive connection
I'll give you cuts scars scoop marks
I'll give you burned earth where the
UFOs land and I'll give you experience
which is consistent among various people
which empirically everybody agrees their
photographs of UFOs it's showing up in
the physical world it may not be of the
physical world as we know it but it
communicates in the physical world and
when something shows up in the physical
world that belongs in the spirit world
that gets the stiff-necked materialists
very excited now they want physical
proof just like in empirical science
because all other faculties of knowledge
have been atrophied but this gets their
attention because it shows up in the
language we understand which is the
physical language you link it to the
anima Mundi then do you think of it as
an ecological danger signal that it's a
message from the earth intelligence
perhaps the earth there are 10 pieces of
evidence that suggest that that's true
one is that the abductees themselves on
the ships receive intense mess
is about ecological destruction
annihilation of whole forest systems
pollution of the water system visions of
the planet dying and they see that on
television like screens they get it
through telepathic communication and
these are not environmentalists these
people they are people who are very
simple ordinary people unremarkable
except that they are getting this
extraordinary information and they
actually become intensely passionately
concerned about the earth and what's
happening to the earth and their
children do because their children may
be abducted as well so that's one piece
of information the other piece of
information is they experience
themselves as not in control being taken
against their wills being treated the
way we treat animals tagged with
implants having physical emotional
experiences in which their utter ly
terrified and without being able to
control what's going on and that for
them brings home how we treat other
creatures on the planet are kind of as
was discussed at a conference conference
in Prague by Ralph Metz are this kind of
humanistic arrogance as if the only
creatures that were really important on
the planet were ourselves and we were
superior in some way to all of the life
work this phenomenon shows us that we
are being treated the way we treat
animals as if they existed only for our
pleasure and they totally transform how
they treat animals how they treat the
earth how they relate to
the environment around it so through
this experience in the body because
that's the important point here this
experience is not just information and
an intellectual sense they experience
these abductions in the body and as
several abductees have said to me we
only know the body now as embodied
creatures if you want to reach us you
have to reach us through the body
because that's the only language we
understand so that tells us that the
creatures are real in some sense well in
what sense I suppose the future can only
tell but maybe it's part of the
unraveling of the end of the millennium
some kind of union of spirit and matter
well John I want to thank you for taking
time off from your busy schedule of
entertaining to come and talk to us I
make one more point when you make okay
if you want to shatter the Western
mental structures the the Western mind
so to speak which is now permeating the
whole earth in its materialist dualistic
philosophy the way you do it is you take
something that's supposed to be in the
spirit world because even in the West we
can make allowance for the spirit world
and we can study it through mythology
for religion through imagination through
poetry but the one unforgivable sin to
the Western mind is when something that
should be in the spirit world
transgresses and shows up in the
physical world that traffic is the
cardinal sin for the Western mind so it
has great power to shatter the belief
structure of the West
mine when that occurs and that's
precisely what's occurring in the
subduction phenomena
very good point thanks very much for
talking with me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]